- This is the one thing I
love learning about you.
So, your-
and I feel like this is like
Blake Shelton on The Voice.
He has, like, a really
wide, like, playlist,
like, variety of music that I would have
never expected on a playlist.
And some of the songs that
are your favorite songs
are my favorite songs,
and I never would've guessed
you would've loved them.
You love some Wham!
- Careless Whisper's my jam, but,
yeah, George Michael?
(applause)
- I mean, that's one of
the greatest songs ever.
- And then you got--
♪ Could've been so good together ♪
Yeah.
- Can I, can I sample you doing that?
- I was just saying that rappers
don't usually jam to Careless Whisper.
- I do, and another thing is,
- Okay, maybe I'm wrong.
I don't know a lot of rappers.
- Well, I do.
No, they don't, 'cause if
I get around certain people
and I play it, they like,
- "What's wrong with you?"
- "You still wanna be friends with Wale?"
(laughter)
- Where did you get the
eclectic taste in music?
- I mean, how can you hear
Wake Me Up Before You Go Go
and not wanna, like, "Yo! Jitterbug."
- What is happening to me?
- And not wanna go go?
- My father drove cabs in D.C.
during one of the most, like,
trying times in that area,
so I would see politicians and--
- You'd ride along with him?
- Yeah, just riding around D.C.
Different people was getting in,
politicians, homeless people,
and I would just hear everything,
and he'd play everything.
He'd buy vinyls and stuff,
and cassettes of things,
because, you know, he's,
at this point, he'd
probably only been in the,
you know, been in the country,
maybe for less than 10 years or so.
He's influenced by things
he would see out there.
You know what I'm saying?
'Cause he was born in Nigeria.
- I love it.
It makes you a great artist I think,
that you're well-rounded.
'Cause, like, seeing your playlist,
like, I love that.
That's the same thing I was
saying about Blake, like,
it's so vast, like, the music knowledge.
And I think that that,
it opens you up instead
of just being like,
"Nah, I don't like that."
You know what I'm saying?
I think that's cool.
- I mean, I told Mark Ronson,
my first tour was with Mark Ronson,
and I toured the world with him.
You know what I'm saying?
And we opened for Jay-Z,
we did everything.
So I was literally, on that specific tour,
I was opening for Jay-Z with Mark,
and I was singing like,
Justice and Chromeo and all these things
when I ain't ever seen nothing like that.
So, that kind of solidified
what my taste is,
when it comes to my career.
- That's really cool, man.
I love that, I love that.
(applause)
So tell us about your new single.
You have a new single, right?
- Yeah, On Chill.
It's kind like my,
I guess,
the template, I guess, if you will,
for like, dating, in this time,
this era right now, where we at.
- So you talk about Tinder?
Just kidding. (laughs)
- By show of hands,
how many people in here are on Tinder?
- You're owning it!
The one owned it!
(applause)
I know that there's more people.
I know that there's more of 'em.
They left you hanging.
- They left you hanging.
- Not cool!
- There's a lot of people in
here on Tinder right now--